para la autoridad palestina es otro
ultraje de israel a medida que avanza
con los planes para construir más de
1.300 nuevas viviendas en cisjordania
sumando a proyectos anteriores que ya
han sido aprobados
el anuncio de 2 mil 862 nuevas viviendas
y la legalización de dos nuevos
asentamientos y unidades de asentamiento
en el corazón de la ciudad de euros no
es más que una flagrante agresión contra
nuestra tierra onesource
los palestinos han buscado durante mucho
tiempo que cisjordania gaza y jerusalén
oriental- sean reconocidos como parte de
su futuro estado israel se apropió de
esas áreas durante la guerra de 1967 y
desde ese entonces todos los gobiernos
han continuado la expansión de
asentamientos unos 475 judíos israelíes
viven en asentamientos de cisjordania
algo que es considerado ilegal por la
comunidad internacional después del
anuncio a eeuu un fiel aliado de israel
expresó su preocupación en cuanto a los
últimos desarrollos creemos que es
fundamental que israel y la autoridad
palestina se abstengan de dar pasos
unilaterales que exacerben la atención y
socaven los esfuerzos para avanzar hacia
una solución negociada los estados esto
ciertamente incluye la actividad de
asentamientos así como la legalización
retroactiva de los mismos para los
grupos palestinos anti colonos esto
demuestra una continuación de las viejas
políticas bajo el gobierno de coalición
del primer ministro naftalí bennett
benet por su parte dice que el estado
palestino ha descartado conversaciones
formales de paz y prefiere enfocarse en
mejoras económicas